this guy got the ball in the first week
of the season scored a couple of
touchdowns he's Josh Jacobs braiders
running back Josh good morning how are
you I'm good are you did you get the
game ball I wouldn't necessarily say
that I've checked the ball school oh
okay so you got the game balls yeah what
did you think of your debut
a month ago I did all right
I think I left a lot of yards on the
table so there's a lot of things I came
into this week's practice with my set
was just trying to get better each week
now you played at Alabama so you're
playing against guys who were future NFL
players but what was the big difference
that you found playing in the NFL in
your first week as opposed to playing in
a big game with Alabama just people a
lot smarter the speed is a little bit
faster but it is really just about smart
the guys in NFL law who surprised you
the most I would say what surprised you
about Von Miller is he as fast as you oh
okay all right did he talk to you
yeah we're talking a little bit yeah it
was funny well did you say anything back
when I watched hard-knock side how did I
not see on Hard Knocks very much was
that on purpose
yeah actually oh mike Mayock to not put
me on so why am I really I really didn't
want any attention I felt like it was a
lot for me to just come in and just
focus on one thing and that's playing
football learning my playbook on the
Middle's and all of that kind of stuff
so I just wanted to keep the main thing
the main thing I guess my eyes to not be
on so that's one how would you sum up
the Antonio Brown
situation with the Raiders okay if you
were telling your buddies what would you
tell him I mean I would just tell them I
guess I mean I don't know it's a very
complicated situation but it was crazy
Josh every day you show up and there was
something new right I mean we didn't
really notice you know so you went to
like your phone or something you seen it
I'm social me like this we never really
noticed all the things that was
happening well we can't lose just
focusing on getting better as a team
biggest difference between Nick Saban
and Jon Gruden is what y'all think Don's
more funny it is there's a lot of
similarities the way they like preparing
and act starting this thing so I'll
probably say that's the biggest thing
what's your favorite Nick Saban story
see it you can say it now because you're
not there he can't he can't punish you
favors just like he likes to do a lot of
like these nice jokes it's funny because
like you I haven't heard one of them
since like middle school and then saving
on with the college save used to do it a
lot wait wait wait wait what give me one
here all right so one day I was testing
I caught like five passes in a row he
was like he like a judge if you want to
hold out it boss hold these I say it
away for a second I was like he was
doing deez nuts to you yeah that's one
of the great stories about saving I've
ever heard wow he seems for did he yell
at you he all the other D one time oh my
whole time there and what and why was
that
I got a flag vitani Omid game
and he got in your face yeah no man
we're talking to Josh Jacobs the Raiders
rookie running back you know your life
story is hard to tell in a couple of
minutes here but it's pretty amazing are
they going to make a movie on your life
have you heard anything about that Oh
what I've been approached by a few
people about doing it
I really haven't made up my mind whether
I wanted to do it or not
so I was right now no how would you sum
that up I mean and I know it's not fair
to you to just give me kind of a Cliff
Notes version of it but it's pretty
amazing Josh what you grew up and and
you know that the man you became and
here you are in the NFL those odds you
probably didn't think when you're
sleeping in the car with your rest of
your family and your dad that you're
gonna end up in the NFL I'm I'm guessing
I mean I mean like I was something I
never thought really this is an affair
was a goal
honestly um game ecology was the biggest
thing for me you know so it's just being
blessed with the opportunity to go
without having like really any looks or
anything like that and so like two weeks
before signing today I mean it's just a
bliss but how would you sum up what your
life was like for somebody who is just
being introduced to you I always say my
life is very hard growing up being five
kids and a single-parent home just
struggling to eat something that
sometimes you know standing struggle to
get things I mean and then at that being
under recruited I mean just like every
time every time you wanted to take a
step up its advice don't own you down so
I say that's probably just the biggest
thing of growing up is just the tough
sort of lifestyle and all that kind of
thing and to fill in some of the gray
area here that Josh and I and I know
you're humble and maybe you don't want
to talk or tired or talking about it but
you know you're you're there with your
dad and a I think a Chevy Suburban and
he's got a gun that's on his lap as you
guys sleep you never saw your dad eat
you weren't sure when you were eating
how you
eating is that kind of a fair assessment
of what was going on
I mean I'm y'all all the things I and
it's a lot of more stuff that I didn't
even quite include that went on and that
was just like aspect of our lifestyles
moved from hotels motels and at one
period of time so it was definitely uh
difficult if I would have told you one
of those days hey hey you're gonna be
the starting running back for the
Oakland Raiders what would you have said
to me I probably would just look at to
the last
hmm who did you grew up rooting for I
didn't have a favorite team I never had
a favorite team I was just kind of like
god I like favorite players well it's a
great story and you know whether you
want to make a movie or not I'm sure
you're gonna get you know people are
gonna look at this is you know you know
the blindside was certainly moving and
emotional but I think this might be
something even bigger than that so and
you might hear from Coach Saban after
the deez nutz story they're just I'm
just saying Josh you might have coach go
Josh let's don't do the deez nutz
anymore okay good luck against Kansas
City and oh and by the way the last time
you ever have to run on that godforsaken
field there at the Oakland Coliseum
right that's such a bad field oh man
can't a man what's that feel like when
you get tackled on that field it might
be judge might be running on rocks hey
you're a great story to root for and
we'll certainly keep an eye on on this
rookie season thank you for joining us
thank you that's Josh Jacobs the Raiders
rookie running back for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]